[Musica]
a realizzare di essere molto fortunata
è stato come accendere la miccia del mio
percorso è il 2014 e mi spediscono in
sud sudan e il contesto mari tario per
eccellenza qui mi dicono dai così impari
bene la mi diranno guarda che mandano
qui le prime missioni solo perché non
sanno dire di no ho 25 anni e per questo
motivo mi mandano in un ospedale che
medici senza frontiere gestisce da più
di vent'anni così che io abbia il tempo
di capire e di imparare osservando ma
faccio solo in tempo a capire che forse
non sono all'altezza del mio compito che
mi ritrovo su una barca sul fiume
sabbath in viaggio verso l'etiopia
insieme i miei colleghi per metterci in
salvo ma come non ero io che ero andata
a salvare gli altri
era successo che la linea del fronte
dove le due etnie del conflitto civile
in corso el inca e non si scontravano
aveva fatto un improvviso balzo in
avanti verso l'ospedale
e questo per noi e smat reati era il
segno che il piano di evacuazione si
doveva mettere in atto senza battere
ciglia per noi espatriati quelli ancora
una volta fortunati mentre viaggiamo
sguardo sulla sponda del fiume e sullo
sfondo vedo i soldati ribelli che vanno
a combattere sfrecciano su delle
camionette malconce sparando in aria due
kalashnikov per darsi la carica
beh tutto sommato quello me l'aspettavo
ero partita per un paese in guerra da
quasi mezzo secolo ma il che cos'è la
guerra
l'ho capito solo quando ha visto in
primo piano una bambina di 5 anni non di
più che camminava nella nostra stessa
direzione
era una piccoletta vestita di stracci
che sembrava terribilmente sapere quello
che doveva fare reggeva un fagotto e un
bastone e all'altro capo del bastone si
faceva guidare una vecchia la sua
bisnonna forse ceca camminavano
permettersi
gli uomini sullo sfondo non erano altro
che ai mariti i fratelli e i padri delle
due in primo piano e mentre penso cala
la notte dopo poche settimane su solo
etiope mi ritrovo di nuovo in struttura
e mi mandano a riaprire la maternità e
in un ospedale che poche settimane prima
durante un attacco era stato raso al
suolo e dato alle fiamme lavoro lì da
qualche mese ormai come spesso succede
il walkie talkie gracchia nella mia
capanna sguardo fuori da quasi l'alba
questo mi rallegra perché nonostante la
giornata precedente sono riuscita a
dormire abbastanza il suono gracchia
quindi non colgo quello che dicono ma
capisco che hanno bisogno di aiuto
quindi mi incammino verso l'ospedale
e sono solo tre minuti a piedi a passo
normale ma quando li percorre lo fai
così alla svelta e lasciando spazio
all'immaginazione su quello che troverai
aprendo la tenda della maternità che in
un attimo sai giallini marco il cancello
sgangherato dell'ospedale e due uomini
che ne escono leggendo una brandina tipo
una rete metallica di un led e capisco
che la situazione che incontrerò un po
come sempre ai limiti
il sud sudan la stragrande maggioranza
della gente abita in capanne di fango e
paglia nel bel mezzo del nulla
non ci sono strade asfaltate non c'è
illuminazione elettrica e se sei
abbastanza fortunato da avere un
ospedale funzionante vicino a te sai che
almeno una ventina di chilometri a piedi
dovrai farti visto che durante la notte
solo la via lattea quello per arte il
cammino e durante la stagione delle
piogge diventa tutto un mare di fango
impraticabile se sei una donna e il tuo
travaglio procede bene ti conviene
partorire nella tua capanna
se invece c'è un problema c'è una
complicanza devi iniziare a sperare di
essere fortunata devi avere la fortuna
che i tuoi cari capiscano che c'è un
problema e decidano importarti in
ospedale non va
la mano del villaggio deve avere la
fortuna che la brandina famosa che è un
bene di lusso ed è condivisa nel
villaggio sia libera è reperibile per
arcana ma soprattutto deve avere la
fortuna che la resistenza del tuo corpo
e possibilmente anche quella del bambino
che porta in grembo sono più forti di
tutte le avversità che incontrerà il
lungo il cammino
beh insomma entra in sala parto è
abbastanza piccola con due letti da
parte abbastanza consuntivi visita una
tenda di plastica un lavandino e una
mensola con sopra i ferri del parto
sterilizzati nell'auto clave carbone
l'ostetrica sud sudanese mi ragguaglia
sul caso è una donna in travaglio del
suo quarto figlio
le contrazioni sono regolari la
dilatazione completa e le spinte sono
intense c'è un unico non trascurabile
dettaglio che è la posizione del feto
questo bambino non vuole nascere di
testa o di sedere podalico ma vuole
nascere di gomito
così il mio cervello apre il tomo di
ostetricia studiato nella mia cara
università di monza che in quel momento
mi sembra anni luce lontana e la
certezza è una sola il parto non è
espletabile per via naturale
serve un taglio cesareo urgente serve
una sala operatoria non degli strumenti
appositi e qualcuno che sappia fare
l'intervento però vi ricordate
dell'ospedale dove sono non c'è lastra
operatoria perché era stata bruciata a
poco tempo prima
so che se quella donna non verrà operata
presto a furia di contrarsi suo utero si
romperà seguirà un emorragia e lei
morirà in modo più o meno rapido ma
terribile esattamente com'era successo
un'altra donna proprio il giorno prima
cosa che io non avevo ancora avuto il
tempo di rielaborare insomma il tempo è
poco quindi chiamo il capovillaggio gli
chiedo se guardiano intera un volo per
trasferire la paziente in capitale
peccato che piove il sud sudan un volo
non s'improvvisa così e non c'è
decolla niente che atterra su un mare di
fango dove la donna i pochi farmaci che
abbiamo a disposizione per cercare di
calmare le contrazioni anche se sa che
il travaglio di una donna sa essere
potente come un tornado e non c'è
farmaco che tenga il battito cardiaco
fetale non si sente più c'è solo la
donna a cui pensare ora passano tre ore
che vi sembrano infinite sì che la
potenza di quel corpo di donna in modo
pressoché inspiegabile all'ostetricia
tradizionale riesce a modellare quel
corpo di figlio senza vita e farlo
passare nel canale del parto e darlo
alla luce la donna è salva evviva
io sono incredula esausta e molto
sollevata in cammino verso la mia
capanna e incontro tito e il
capovillaggio sud sudanese un uomo alto
magro senza un occhio e coi denti
davanti belli separati tipico dei noir
lui in quanto capo villaggio sa già
quello che è successo in sala parto a
maria si congratula con me anch'io cerco
di chiarire gli dico che io non ho fatto
un bel niente e che la donna è stata
solo molto fortunata e gli dico
she was just lucky e lui mi sorride e mi
dice la kings good ileana lucky red il
sudan mi resta nel cuore nel 2016 quando
mi propongono di tornarci accetto senza
neanche pensare mi mandano in un enorme
campo profughi a 130 chilometri a nord
dal posto dove ero stata della prima
missione e li ho di nuovo una grande
fortuna incontro alcuni dei colleghi sud
sudanesi con cui avevo già lavorato
l'altra volta
sono troppo felice di ritrovarli vivi
tra un parte l'altro mi raccontano del
perché sono dovuti scappare del come
l'hanno fatto e visto che le
rappresaglie si intensificavano al
calare del sole
la gente che scappava doveva avanzare
durante il giorno e nascondersi nelle
paludi durante la notte
dovevano passare la notte con in braccio
i bambini perché il fango arrivava alla
loro vita
roda è un ostetrica molto in gamba oltre
che di una bellezza unica e mi racconta
delle donne che si vedevano in travaglio
durante quelle nottate e dei parti
assistiti con il nulla dei cordoni
ombelicali d'italia tico di pezzi di
lamiera e c'è un parto nello specifico
il cui ricordo è come se non la
lasciasse tranquilla continua a
ripetermi le manovre che ha fatto per
salvare i bambini perché era un parto
gemellare
e come per cercare la mia approvazione
perché io le dico che che è stata una
grande e che per quella madre quei
bambini lei è stata un vero dono di vita
e che sono stati fortunati e penso di
nuovo alla chi svolge questa e mille
altre storie mi fanno pensare che i
nostri colleghi lega bilocali sono i
veri eroi
nonostante siano loro le prime vittime
della guerra hanno la forza di venire a
lavorare con noi di giorno e di notte
per prendersi cura dei nostri pazienti
seppur traumatizzati hanno la forza di
venire e lenire il trauma della loro
gente
e come se sapessero mettere in pausa il
ricordo degli orrori che vivono ogni
giorno dei parenti degli amici ammazzati
degli stupri della fame per venire a
prendersi cura dei nostri pazienti che
sono a volte i loro nemici quando nel
2017 abbiamo aperto una materialità nel
kurdistan iracheno a pochi chilometri da
dove si svolgeva la battaglia per la
liberazione di mussolini rist trovare
delle ostetriche disposte a venire a
lavorare insieme a noi vicino al fronte
è stato quasi impossibile perché tutti
avevano paura giustamente finalmente
riesco a mettere insieme un team molto
eterogeneo mix di curde irachene di
asili
siriane e se pensate alla storia di
tutti questi popoli vi sembrerà
impossibile eppure loro lavoravano
insieme in sala parto in prima linea per
prendersi cura di altri cura di altre
donne
stremati dalla guerra passa un anno e
come ostetrica sono molto entusiasta
perché mi propongono di andare in una
delle più grandi maternità del mondo a
khost in afghanistan
parlo di una vera e propria fabbrica di
bambini che ne sforna più di 23 mila
all'anno che sono una sessantina in
media al giorno ma alle volte anche un
centinaio sono numeri da far girare la
testa che non mi sembrano possibili
neanche dopo esserci stata quindi italia
se se assist i tre parti in una notte
sei era autorizzata sentirti tosta nella
ricordo le ostetriche afghane
letteralmente collassata a terra dopo un
turno di 14 ore di notte in quel caos
dove due o tre donne travaglia vano
nello stesso letto una realtà ai limiti
dove la vita nasce dove la vita resiste
un po come per b b che partorisce la sua
quarta figlia sulle montagne e arriva da
noi che è incosciente shock emorragico e
quasi morta per provare a salvarla non
ci resta che volare in sala operatoria e
toglierle l'utero per farlo però abbiamo
bisogno del permesso del marito che non
è sempre una cosa facile da ottenere
quindi corro da lui insieme
all'interprete è partita un po prevenuta
come è pronta a doverlo convincere
usando del tempo che in quegli attimi
non c'è invece mi trovo davanti un uomo
di montagna con la pelle bruciata dal
sole e la barba lunga
mi sembra un povero tra i poveri che mi
ascolta attento forse non coglie tutto
quello che dico ma capisce che non gli
resta che darci piena fiducia e appone
impronta digitale sul foglio del
consenso informato perché non sa chi non
sa firmare in afghanistan non mi ha
neanche permesso di guardare un uomo
negli occhi tra i rom
io lo vorrei abbracciare
sotto i ferri il cuore di b b
si ferma non una ma ben due volte e poi
riparte cosa quasi inverosimile quegli
strumenti che abbiamo a nostra
disposizione
la situazione estremamente critica però
l'intervento termina ebb ancora viva
durante la notte però la situazione
degenera di nuovo il suo sangue è come
impazzito non coagula più quindi non ci
resta che tornare in sala operatoria e
riempire la sua pancia di garze per
cercare di fermare il sanguinamento
richiuderla e stare a vedere
e cosi facciamo passano due giorni nella
situazione sembra tenere quindi ci
prepariamo per tornare in sala
operatoria e togliere quelle garze che
sembra abbiano fatto il loro lavoro
quindi si ri prepariamo di nuovo siamo
tutti molto tesi
lavoriamo in modo silenzioso e preciso
dal proprio bimbi a rompere quel
silenzio perché ci guarda impasto dice
state tranquilli che io ce la faccio e
così succede dopo tre settimane di
diesel e tornano sulle sue montagne la
sua bambina ed è piena di vita she was
just like la chi mi ascolta fortuna è
vita vita e fortuna a braccetto quella
fortuna che io ho avuto realizzare di
averla mi ha fatto vibrare e mi ha
spinto lontano per cercare di
restituirla quella fortuna che ho visto
essere l'ago della bilancia tra la morte
e la vita quella vita che va onorata e
apprezzata cercando quello che ci fa
vibrare ea voi che cosa vi fa sentire
vivi che cosa vi fa vibrare
[Applauso]
[Musica]